>>> ALL RIGHT GREAT TO BE HERE
WHO KNEW I COULD STAY UP LATER
THAN MOST CHILDREN IN AMERICA.
IT'S TRUE I CAN.
IT'S FUN TO SEE EXCLAMATION
POINTS EVERYWHERE ON THIS SET ON
THE POSTERS, ON THE NAME AND
ALSO ON THE PLEASE LAUGH SIGNS.
I DIDN'T KNOW THAT HE HAD THOSE
BUT THAT ACTUALLY PROBABLY HELPS
THE SHOW A LITTLE BIT.
THE SET STAFF IS PLEASED BECAUSE
GREG AND I SHARE THE SAME SIZE
BOOSTER SEAT AND THE SAME SIZE
SHOE.
ALL RIGHT, LOOK, FOR ANYONE
BATTLING ADDICTIONS OR LOTS OF
BIG PROBLEMS IF THEIR LIVES THE
FIRST STEP TO RECOVERY IS
ADMITTING YOU HAVE A PROBLEM AND
THAT'S NOT EASY TO DO.
THEN YOU HAVE TO ACCEPT THAT YOU
HAVE TO GET UP OFF YOUR DID YOU
HAVE AND COMMIT TO MAKING THINGS
BETTER.
THAT'S RIGHT I SAID DUFF AND
THAT'S THE KIND OF SALTY
LANGUAGE YOU WILL GET FROM DANA
PERINO AFTER DARK.
SO HERE'S WHAT YOU DO.
YOU MAKE A PLAN, YOU TACKLE THE
ISSUE, YOU TRY TO CHANGE YOUR
CIRCUMSTANCES, YOU GET BETTER
RESULTS AND SOLVE YOUR PROBLEM.
YOU CAN'T JUST SIT BACK BLAME
OTHERS AND EXPECT EVERYTHING TO
BE OKAY.
OR CAN YOU?
LET'S SEE HOW THE LEADER OF THE
FREE WORLD IS APPROACHING HIS
SET OF PROBLEMS.
HE'S SETTING RECORDS ALL OVER
THE PLACE.
RECORD INFLATION, RECORD GAS
PRICES, RECORD INCREASES IN
CRIME WHICH HAS LED TO RECORD
LOW POLL NUMBERS.
THE ONE THING HE'S BEEN ABLE TO
DO IS BRING EVERYBODY TOGETHER
ON ONE QUESTION.
A WHOOPING RECORD 74 PEOPLE
SURVEYED IN A RECENT POLL
BELIEVE THE COUNTRY IS ON THE
WRONG TRACK.
THEY'VE EVEN BROKEN THE RECORD
FOR AUDACITY.
YOU CANNOT HELP BUT LAUGH AT
WHAT THE PRESIDENT THINKS SHOULD
BE A DEBT RECOVERY.
THE HISTORIC AIRLIFT FROM
AFGHANISTAN.
THE HISTORIC SHIPMENTS OF BABY
FORMULA FROM EUROPE.
THE HISTORIC RELEASE FROM THE
PETROLEUM RESERVE AND HE SOUNDS
LIKE A BROKEN RECORD AS HE TRIES
TO BLAME EVERYONE BUT HIMSELF.
>> THIS IS OUTRAGES WHAT THE WAR
IN UKRAINE IS CAUSING.
>> WE'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING
LIKE PUTIN'S TAX ON BOTH FOOD
AND GAS.
>> EXXON MADE MORE MONEY THAN
GOD THIS YEAR.
>> WHY AREN'T THEY DRILLING?
BECAUSE THEY MAKE MORE MONEY NOT
PRODUCING MORE OIL.
>> MY REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES SAY
THESE PROGRAMS HELP THE WORKING
CLASS AND MIDDLE CLASS PEOPLE.
THEY SAY THAT'S WHY THEY HAVE
INFLATION.
THEY'RE DEAD WRONG.
UNDER MY PREDECESSOR, THE GREAT
MAGA KING, THE DEFICIT INCREASED
EVERY SINGLE YEAR HE WAS
PRESIDENT.
>> Dana: HE EVEN HAS DECIDED TO
BLAME HIS MOST LOYAL REMAINING
FRIENDS, THE MEDIA.
>> LOOK AT HOW THE PRESS HAS
CHANGED.
LOOK HOW THE PRESS HAS CHANGED.
>> IT HAS CHANGED, I GET IT.
>> EVEN THE REALLY GOOD
REPORTERS THEY HAVE TO GET A
NUMBER OF CLICKS ON THE NIGHTLY
NEWS.
SO INSTEAD OF ASKING THE
QUESTION -- ANYWAY.
EVERYTHING GETS SENSATIONALIZED.
>> Dana: ANYWAY.
IT GOT SO BAD THAT A COUPLE OF
WEEKS AGO AFTER GOING ABOUT 120
DAYS WITHOUT DOING A SINGLE
INTERVIEW WITH ANY REPORTER, HE
SAINTERED BACK TO THE PRESS
CABIN ON AIR FORCE ONE TO
COMPLAIN ABOUT HIS PRESS
COVERAGE AND GET THIS IT WAS OFF
THE RECORD.
EVEN THE REPORTERS WERE TAKEN
ABACK.
THE BIDEN CABINET AND HIS
COMMUNICATIONS TEAM HAVE PICKED
UP ON THIS.
DON'T BLAME US, BLAME YOURSELVES
MEDIA.
WHICH IS STRANGE TO ME BECAUSE I
KNOW POLITICAL COMMUNICATIONS
VERY WELL.
HAS ANYONE IN THIS ROOM EVER
HEARD THAT I WAS THE WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY TO PRESIDENT
GEORGE H.W. BUSH?
I'M SURE YOU HEARD IT?
I STARTED OUT AT A YOUNG HILL
STAFFER --
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Dana: I DON'T GET APPLAUSE.
I JUST THOUGHT IT WAS FUNNY THAT
I ALSO SAY IT WAY TOO MUCH AND
EVERYBODY CERTAINLY KNOWS.
I DIDN'T START OUT AS WHITE
HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY I WAS A
YOUNG STAFFER ON THE HILL, ALL
THIS OPTIMISM SUPER EXCITED TO
MAKE SURE THE ISSUES WERE
COVERED FAIRLY AND MY REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMEN COULD GET A FAIR
SHOT IN THE PRESS.
OH HOW INNOCENT I WAS.
IT LASTED LIKE FOUR DAYS.
YOU SEE, THE EASIEST JOB IN
WASHINGTON IS A DEMOCRATIC
COMMUNICATIONS STAFFER.
THE HARDEST JOB, PREPARING THE
TELL PROMPTER AFTER KAMALA GOES
OFF SCRIPT.
THINK ABOUT IT, THE REPORTERS
WRITE WHAT YOU WANT WRITTEN.
THEY AGREE TO KEEP YOUR COMMENTS
TO STAFFER MORE ANONYMOUS THAN A
LIST OF MEN WHO WATCH THE VIEW.
THEY RUN COVER FOR YOU.
EVEN THE PRESS WILL WRITE THAT
IT'S NOT JUST FAULT THAT IN SAN
FRANCISCO THERE'S LOOTING OR
FECAL MATTER ON EVERY STREET
CORNER.
THERE'S THINGS HARDER, DWAYNE
JOHNSON'S PERSONAL TRAINER.
SNACK WRANGLER FOR BRIAN
STELTER.
>> BOOM.
>> Dana: SORRY BRIAN.
JUST FILLING IN.
AND GREG'S PERSONAL SHOPPER, OF
COURSE.
[LAUGHTER].
>> Dana: AND THEN STAFFERS WILL
LAUGH BEHIND THE REPORTERS BACK
KNOWING THEY USED THEM TO MEET
THEIR GOAL.
BUT I DO FEEL FOR THE COM
STAFFER IN A WAY BECAUSE HERE IS
A PERINO RULE.
WHENEVER YOU HEAR SOMEONE HAS A
COMMUNICATIONS PROBLEM SAY
IMMEDIATELY NO.
COMMUNICATIONS ARE CAUSED BY
FACT PROBLEMS, POLICY PROBLEMS
AND NO POLICY PROBLEM IN THE
HISTORY OF THE WORLD WAS EVER
SOLVED BY A CHANGE IN MESSAGING.
BELIEVE ME I'VE TRIED LARRY WILL
REMEMBER THAT.
THIS ISN'T A COMMUNICATIONS
PROBLEM.
IT'S A JOE BIDEN PROBLEM.
A COMMUNICATIONS PROBLEM IS WHEN
HIS MIC DOESN'T WORK.
A JOE BIDEN PROBLEM IS WHEN IT
DOES.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Dana: THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS
OFFICE DOESN'T HAVE MUCH TO WORK
WITH.
THEY AREN'T MAKING NEW POLICIES.
WATCH HERE.
>> WE UNDERSTAND THESE GAS
PRICES INCLUDING FOOD PRICES IN
PARTICULAR, THOSE TWO THINGS AS
WE LOOK AT INFLATION AND TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE FIGHTING
INFLATION IN EVERY WAY THAT WE
CAN, IS HURTING FAMILIES.
IT'S HURTING FAMILIES ESPECIALLY
AS THEY SIT AROUND THEIR KITCHEN
TABLE.
BUT WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
DO EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN.
I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO PREVIEW
FOR YOU.
>> Dana: THEY'RE ALSO LIVING
WITH THE CONSEQUENCES OF BIDEN'S
POLICIES.
WE ALL ARE.
AND WE'RE REMINDED OF IT LEFT
AND RIGHT.
GAS, GROCERIES, BABY FORMULA,
THE LIST GOES ON.
HOW HARD IS IT TO FIGURE OUT
THAT YOU CAN'T MESSAGE INFLATION
AWAY?
ANYWAYS, LET'S JUST SAY THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WATCHES GUTFELD,
LET'S SAY THEY DO GUTFELD
EXCLAMATION POINT AND TAKE MY
ADVISE AND START TO ADMIT THEY
HAVE A PROBLEM AND THEY TRY TO
START TO SOLVE THEM.
THE LAST STEP OF RECOVERY WOULD
BE NEXT, AND THAT IS ADMITTING
YOUR WRONGS AND MAKING AMENDS TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IT'S UNLIKELY THAT THE PRESIDENT
WILL BE DOING THAT.
SO IT'S EVERY MAN FOR HIMSELF,
AND AT LEAST WE HAVE EACH OTHER.
♪
>> PERIOD!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Dana: LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUESTS, HE'S LIKE A COMPANY THAT
RENTS OUT BOUNCY HOUSES, ALWAYS
WORRIED ABOUT INFLATION.
HE'S THE HOST OF KUDLOW ON FOX
BUSINESS, LARRY KUDLOW.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Dana: HE'S ON A NUMBER OF
WHO'S WHOSE LIST BECAUSE NO ONE
KNOWS WHO HE IS, THE HOST OF FOX
ACROSS AMERICA, JIMMY FAILLA!
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Dana: FOR HIM WORKING
REMOTELY MEANS MOVING TO ALASKA,
ACTOR WRITER AND COMEDIAN JAMIE
LaSALLE.
AND SHE GETS CARRIED AWAY WHEN
HOLDING HELIUM BALLOONS, FOX
NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Dana: ALL RIGHT WE'RE IN NO
TURNING BACK NOW.
LARRY YOU THINK PRESIDENT BIDEN
RUNS AGAIN IN 2024?
AND IF HE DECIDES NOT TO IS IT
AGE OR IS THE ECONOMY NOT GOING
TO GET ANY BETTER?
>> WELL, IT'S GOING TO BE BOTH.
GOT TO BE BOTH.
I MEAN, I DON'T WANT TO BE
ACCUSED OF AGEISM SO I'LL JUST
SAY WITH ALL HIS POLICY
MISTAKES, I REALLY LIKED YOUR AA
12 STEP ROUTINE.
>> Dana: DID I NAIL IT?
>> Larry:.
>> Larry: YOU'VE GOT TO OWN IT
AND DEAL WITH IT AND WHEN YOU
WERE WRONG YOU SHOULD PROMPTLY
ADMIT IT.
OF COURSE THEY WON'T DO THAT.
HE'S LIVING IN SOME KIND OF
ALTERNATE UNIVERSE.
AND UNFORTUNATELY THE COUNTRY'S
PAYING THE PRICE FOR THIS RIGHT
NOW.
YOU SEE, INFLATION RECORD,
STOCKS ARE GETTING KILLED,
INTERESTS RATES ARE GOING UP,
REAL WAGES ARE FALLING, YOU WENT
THROUGH THE LIST, I HAPPEN TO
AGREE.
HE CAN'T POSSIBLY RUN ON THAT
RECORD.
SO I THINK HE'S PROBABLY TOO
OLD, OKAY, BUT.
>> Dana: AND YOU CAN'T MESSAGE
AWAY INFLATION.
THEY CAN'T START TALKING ABOUT
IT IN A DIFFERENT WAY AND MAKE
INFLATION BETTER.
>> Larry: YOUR OTHER POINT IS
EXACTLY RIGHT.
THERE'S NO SUCH THING AS A
COMMUNICATION POLICY IT'S ABOUT
POLICY AND SUBSTANCE AND WHAT
YOU'RE DOING AND ARE YOU HURTING
OR HELPING THE COUNTRY.
NVSH THE COUNTRY OUTSIDE OF THE
BIDEN WHITE HOUSE UNDERSTANDS
THAT THE COUNTRY IS VASTLY WORSE
OFF.
SO HE CAN'T POSSIBLY RUN.
BUT, LOOK, THE SEMIFINALS IS
GOING TO BE IN NOVEMBER.
HE'S GOING TO GET SLAUGHTERED,
THE CALVARY'S COMING AND THINGS
ARE GOING TO GET BETTER I LIKE
TO BE AN OPTIMIST.
>> Dana: YES YOU ARE THAT'S WHY
WE LOVE YOU AND KEEP HAVING YOU
BACK.
>> Larry: THIS MUST CHANGE AND
AS IS ALWAYS THE CASE IN AMERICA
WHICH IS THE GREATEST COUNTRY IT
WILL.
>> Dana: I AGREE ABSOLUTELY.
JIMMY CAN DID MEDIA BE BETTER
WHEN IT COMES TO BIDEN'S PRESS
COVERAGE?
CAN THEY BE MORE HELPFUL TO HIM?
>> Jimmy: NO, BECAUSE EVERY
QUESTION IS A TOUGH QUESTION.
WHEN YOU ASK JOE BIDEN WHAT
STATE HE'S IN, HE GETS IT WRONG
QUITE FREQUENTLY.
SO WHAT ARE WE SUPPOSED TO DO
WITH JOE BIDEN, THE ONLY GUY WE
KNOW WHO QUITS TALKING IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE SENTENCE BECAUSE
HE'S DONE.
YOU UNDERSTAND?
LIKE, DUDE, THIS GUY IS SENDING
IN THE PUNT TEAM ON SECOND DOWN.
THAT'S NOT HOW IT'S SUPPOSED TO
WORK.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE HIM RUN
AGAIN THOUGH JUST BECAUSE
SOMEBODY WOULD HAVE TO SELL
THIS -- LIKE COULD YOU IMAGINE
ASKING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO
VOTE FOR THIS GUY AGAIN?
THAT'S LIKE HANDING OUT SHOES ON
A LIFE BOAT ON THE TITANIC.
BUT THINK ABOUT MONDAY THROUGH
THURSDAY WEREN'T THOSE GOOD
DINNERS?
[LAUGHTER]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Jimmy: SERIOUSLY.
BUT SERIOUSLY HERE'S THE ONLY
UPSIDE TO THE BIDEN PRESIDENCY,
I'M A SILVER LINING GUY AND I
REALLY AM.
THE ONLY IMPROVEMENT IN THE
QUALITY OF LIFE UNDER BIDEN IS
ARSONS ARE DOWN 90% BECAUSE NO
ONE DID BURN DOWN YOUR HOUSE AT
5:15 A GALLON.
IF SOMEONE BURNS DOWN YOUR HOUSE
RIGHT NOW DANA YOU SHOULD BE
FLATTERED.
>> Dana: ALL THOSE HARD EARNED
DOLLARS.
CAT THE CALLS ARE COMING FROM
INSIDE THE HOUSE NOW THE
DEMOCRATS ARE NOW WHISPERING TO
THE NEW YORK TIMES ANONYMOUSLY
SAYING YOU CAN'T BE OUR NOMINEE
IN 2024
>> Kat: YEAH, BUT THEY STILL
DON'T REALLY GET IT.
SOME OF THE PEOPLE IN THAT
ARTICLE THAT WERE ON THE RECORD
LIKE DAVID AXLE ROD SAYING ONE
OF THE PROBLEM IS THAT BIDEN
LOOKS HIS AGE.
LIKE I DON'T THINK LIP
INJECTIONS ARE GOING TO SOLVE
IT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Kat: AND HE DOES PROVE TO ME,
I UNDERSTAND WHAT AGE IS JUST A
NUMBER MEANS BECAUSE MY
GRANDPARENTS ARE TEN YEARS OLDER
THAN JOE BIDEN AND THEY'RE WAY
BETTER AT WORDS.
LIKE I WOULD BE SO CONCERNED IF
I HEARD EITHER ONE OF THEM
TALKING LIKE THIS AND THEY'RE
NOT THE LEADER OF THE FREE
WORLD.
I THINK THAT PEOPLE ARE MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT EVERYTHING
THAT'S GOING WRONG.
THERE'S INFLATION.
PEOPLE ARE STRUGGLING, AND IT'S,
YOU KNOW, KIND OF THE EQUIVALENT
OF WHEN YOU SEND A FRIEND A TEXT
AND THEY REALLY NEED SOME HELP
YOU HAVE A REALLY BAD DAY AND
THEY GO DAM THAT SUCKS.
THEY'RE LIKE YEAH, WE KNOW,
WE'RE -- ARE YOU?
IT'S NOT JUST THAT IT'S BAD.
>> Dana: AS GREG SAYS LIKE
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW WHAT INFLATION
IS.
THEY KNOW IT EVERY DAY.
GREG SENT IN A QUESTION FOR YOU.
I WOULD NEVER SAY THIS, OKAY?
AS A DIVORCED MAN, DO YOU BLAME
ALL YOUR PROBLEMS ON YOUR
EX-WIFE?
[LAUGHTER].
>> ACTUALLY I DEFINITELY BLAME
HER FOR THE DIVORCE.
IT WAS HER IDEA.
BUT DANA, YOU ARE SO RIGHT IN
YOUR MONOLOGUE THAT THIS IS NOT
A COMMUNICATION PROBLEM, IT IS A
FACT PROBLEM.
EVEN IN THE SHORT POST WE SAW HE
SAID EXXON HAS MORE MONEY THAN
GOD.
I DON'T THINK GOD EVEN HAS
MONEY.
LIKE IN EVERY PICTURE I'VE SEEN
HE DOESN'T EVEN HAVE POCKETS.
YOU KNOW?
AND, LIKE, DID YOU GUYS READ --
THERE WAS ONE ARTICLE THAT
DIDN'T QUITE -- LIKE THE TEXT
DIDN'T COME UP IN WHAT WE TALKED
ABOUT BUT IT WAS BIDEN
COMPLAININGS PEOPLE THROWING
STUFF ON HIS DESK.
EVERY TIME I LOOK UP THERE'S
MORE STUFF THROWN ON MY DESK.
YOU'RE LOOK I CAN THE PRESIDENT
RIGHT?
LIKE THERE'S STUFF TO DO.
AND THAT'S NOT JUST STUFF.
THOSE ARE LIFE-SAVING
MEDICATIONS.
DON'T YOU THINK -- I THINK KAT
IS SO RIGHT THAT AGE REALLY IS
JUST A NUMBER AND WE KNOW PEOPLE
THAT ARE MUCH OLDER THAT ARE
SPRY AND SHARP.
I'VE HEARD PEOPLE SAY HE'S AN
OLD 79.
AND I LIKE TO PUT A POSITIVE
SPIN ON IT.
I THINK HE'S LIKE A YOUNG 115.
YOU KNOW?
OR LIKE A YOUTHFUL DRACULA.
>> Jimmy:
>> Larry: CAN I JUST SAY IF THE
ECONOMY WAS BOOMING AND PRICES
WERE STABLE AND GASES WERE LOW
WHEN DONALD TRUMP LEFT AS I
MIGHT ADD.
IF THE UNITED STATES WERE EXPECT
RESPECTED AROUND THE WORLD.
>> Dana: A LOT OF Fs.
>> Larry: IF HE HADN'T BUNGLED
AFGHANISTAN NO ONE WOULD CARE
ABOUT HIS AGE.
I DON'T MAKE THE AGE PART TOO
HARD.
ALL I'M SAYING IS IT'S WHAT HE'S
DONE AND THE HARM HE'S DONE
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY ON HIS
POLICIES AND THE FACT YOU
MENTIONED EARLIER HE WON'T
ACKNOWLEDGE ANY OF IT.
HE'S NEVER TO BLAME THE GUY IS
THE LEAST INTROSPECTIVE PERSON
I'VE EVER SEEN IN MY LIFE AND